so what we're going to do in this video
is build our muscles at comparing
numbers that are represented in
different ways so for example right over
here on the Left we have 0.37 you could
also view this as 37 hundredths and on
the right we have 307 thousands and so
what I want you to do is pause this
video and figure out are these equal to
each other or is one of them larger than
the other and if one of them is which
one is larger and which one is smaller
pause this video and try to figure that
out all right now let's try to do this
together and the way that my brain works
as I try to put them into a common
representation so one way we could do it
is we could try to rewrite this one on
the right as a decimal so let's do that
so we could rewrite this as it's
expressing a certain number of thousands
and so let me just make some blanks for
our various places so let's say that's
the ones place and that's our decimal
that's going to be our tenths place
that's going to be our hundredths place
and that's going to be our thousandths
place
so one way to view three hundred and
seven thousandths is that we have three
hundred and seven of this place right
over there so we could just write the
seven there the zero there and the three
over there this over here would be three
hundred and seven thousandths and so we
would have no ones and so when you look
at it this way it's a little bit easier
to compare you can say alright we have
the same number of ones we have the same
number of tenths and let me compare the
like ones to like ones so our tenths are
equal but what happens when we get to
the hundredths here we have seven
hundredths and here we have zero
hundredths so this this number on the
left is going to be larger so 37
hundredths is greater than three hundred
and seven thousands another way that we
could have done this is we could have
re-expressed this left number in terms
of thousandths
we could have rewritten it as instead of
37 hundredths we could have just said
zero point three seven and just put
another zero on the right
and this is 370 thousands I'll write it
out 370 thousands and when you look at
it this way once again it's clear that
370 of something is more than 307 of
that something so this quantity on the
left is larger let's do another example
but I'll use different formats so let's
say on the left I'll use decimal format
I'll have zero point six or six tenths
and then on the right I'm going to have
six times one over a hundred pause this
video and tell me which of these
quantities if either are greater or are
they equal to each other all right so
once again in order to tackle this you
really just have to think about what are
different ways to represent them and
really just try to get to a common
representation and so I could rewrite
six tenths as six times 1/10 six times
1/10 and this might be enough to be able
to compare the two because six times
1/10 is that going to be greater than or
less than or equal to six times one
hundredths well a tenth is ten times
larger than a hundredth so because this
is ten times larger than that if you
multiply it by six well this is going to
be a larger quantity so we could go and
say hey this is greater than that
another way that you might have realized
that is if you were to express this
right quantity as a decimal like this so
this is six times a hundred or six
hundredths so we could write that's our
ones
that's our tenths and then in our
hundredths place you would have six and
if it isn't obvious that this is less
than that
you could add a zero here and this we
would read as 60 hundredths and 60
hundredths is for sure
larger than six hundredths so these are
all very reasonable ways of re
representing these numbers and putting
them in the same format so we can make
the comparison and realize the one on
the left actually in both scenarios is
larger than the one on the right